this is a tough one you know usually
when you say I want to talk about
so-and-so you know either half a dozen
things immediately springing to my mind
or I kind of think about it and I go
away and read a couple of journal
articles and you know find out a bit
about but maybe any field of Mars or
whatever it is but earth is
simultaneously there's too little to say
too much to say in that you know
obviously there's masses a masses of
things you could talk about about the
earth but actually you know most people
know about most of them already but
there are several characteristics about
earth that make it unique among the
other planets so among the terrestrial
planets which are Mercury Venus Earth
and Mars Earth happens to be the biggest
it's the most massive it's the most
dense so it has more stuff smashed into
its volume than the other planets this
is the first picture ever taken off the
earth from Mars so the one of the probes
turned around and took a photo of the
earth and you can see this tiny speck in
the middle and that's the earth seen
from us you know as an astronomical
object earth really isn't that
spectacular you know it's a sort of
middle sized planet in the somewhere in
the middle of the solar system
so from an astronomical point of view
again apart from the fact that you know
it's the only place that we know about
in life in the in the universe there
really isn't that much and that's such a
headline item but after that I'm
struggling a bit to think of anything
interesting to say about the planet that
we have to live on it also has tectonic
activity so the crust the pieces of the
crust are split up into chunks and they
move around which we feel as as
earthquakes the the twin of the earth is
Venus right it's a planet very very like
the earth in a lot of ways it's very
non-conductive to life on Venus because
it's in a way way hotter has this
runaway greenhouse effect at all but it
if you were just looking at planets and
comparing them you would see two fairly
cloud-covered reasonably warm planets
with rocky cores and magnetic fields in
their middle and so on and if you were
really that uninspired by life there
isn't really anything that would make
you pick the earth out as the most
spectacular place to visit in the solar
system the interior of Earth we can
study a bit because we actually live
here so we can feel how the planet moves
around there's a solid iron core and
then there's a liquid core around that
and then there's a mantle and then
there's the crust on the outside so when
the planet formed from the solar nebula
it was probably
mostly molten iron and other chemicals
and things built up and so it stays
liquid but probably after 10 or 20
million years the outer crust cooled and
solidified so that's where we got the
crust but the inner part stayed very hot
that's unusual yeah that probably is the
single thing that's most different about
it I guess something in the solar system
has to have the biggest moon relative to
the size of the planet and actually even
that's not quite true because Pluto's
moon is pretty big compared to it as
well but so maybe yeah maybe even the
moon wouldn't stand out that much as a
you know a spectacular feature of the
earth because as moons all over the
solar system maybe people would notice
that we only have one you know most
planets have more than one Lucie outer
planets do this is a very famous picture
it's actually tilted it should be 90
degrees switch counterclockwise would
take it this is probably the most famous
picture of the earth and I think it's
called the most printed picture ever
made this is taken by Apollo 8 so this
is not from the surface of the Moon but
from the orbit around it and this is
basically an earth rise so again I'm
struggling to find anything spectacular
to say about the earth other than the
fact we're here and that kind of sounds
a bit egotistical really if you were
actually flying over earth and you were
looking at it it would look quite
interesting people call it the Blue
Marble
so you see oceans this deep blue about
70% of the earth is covered in oceans
and you also see the white clouds that's
pretty unique to earth though water
vapor condenses into these clouds and so
we get this nice water cycle and then
we've got these land masses and you see
some brighter parts where it's covered
with sand and deserts and the green
portions where we actually have trees
and photosynthesis happening so this is
a pretty unique view of Earth from above
so five seasons but again that doesn't
really make it stand out in the in the
solar system in that you know most so
what causes the seasons is the fact that
the Earth's axis is tilted relative to
its orbit around so that sometimes it's
leaning towards the Sun sometimes it's
leaning away from the Sun but other
other planets do exactly the same thing
so again there's not not even seasonal
variations is not something that's
unique to the earth this is a picture
way which i think is really impressive
because it
it's taken I think from the space
station and it's a sunrise behind the
Earth and what you can see is basically
you can see a bit the curvature of the
earth and what you see is the atmosphere
being lit by the Sun in the background
and you can really see how thin this
layer actually is their atmosphere is
only like 100 kilometres thick I have
read some people suggest that how do we
know there's not another earth another
planet exactly the same as ours on the
exact opposite side of the Sun going
around at the same speed so we never see
it it's been a popular one it's been
around in science fiction since time
immemorial and you know you look on your
favorite conspiracy theory website
you'll find out about it
we know there isn't and part of the
reason we know we're there isn't be
pretty unlikely to actually end up with
the planet there but now we have much
more direct evidence because of course
if you it's true that if the were of
Planet exactly around the other side of
the of the Sun following exactly a sort
of mirrored orbit so it kept pace with
us and when the earth slows down on its
orbit this one slows down as well and so
on we wouldn't be able to see it we
would however be able to detect its
gravitational influence on the other
planets just as we can detect the
Earth's influence on gravitational
influence on the other planets it's not
there and actually even more directly
than that of course yes sitting on the
earth we can't see what's on the other
side of the Sun but we sent spent plenty
of probes out into space now and they've
looked and there's nothing at all there
there's nothing to see so there is no
mirror earth on the other side of the
Sun